This is Cardboard, a virtual
reality viewer anyone can make.
Just insert your phone and
immerse yourself in 3D.
In fact, it is so
simple, you can even
make it out of a cereal box.
My name is Shanee,
and in this series
we're going to find out what is
Google Cardboard, how it works,
and how to make virtual
reality applications.
Virtual reality in a cereal box?
How do you do that?
It all starts with a box.
These cardboard pieces
assemble into the viewer.
Add in your everyday
phone, acting as a screen.
Two plastic lenses focus
your wide field of view
into the screen, putting you
inside the virtual world.
You interact with the game
using a magnet on the side.
The components are so simple.
You can make your own Cardboard
viewer out of almost anything.
To make your own, just
download the blueprint,
get the basic components,
cut, and assemble.
Check out the link
below for instructions.
Or, if you're like me, and
don't like cutting things,
then why not get one online?
To learn more about
how Cardboard works
and how to develop for
it, check out the rest
of the videos or the docs.
So until next time.